[Music]
it seems to me that there's something
absolutely central that the life we lead
is actually determined to some extent by
the kind of creatures we think that we
are that's what it is to lead a life
rather than merely act out a biological
prescription I think that's something
actually central and where do we get
that sense of who or what we are from we
get it from the community of minds so we
have to recognize there is something
absolutely central about the community
of minds which is not implanted in
particular brain that actually shapes
the kind of persons that we are and
that's why the brain in the vat
experiment one of the many reasons
thought experiment doesn't work the
first is you have to assume that
somebody has put the brain in the vat
that there is an outside world of people
creating this kind of situation so as it
presupposes the very things the outside
world that the brain in bat experiment
plays with suspending but the other
thing is that yes you could indeed get
experiences from stimulating the brain
and let me give you some very striking
example from The Canadian neurosurgeon
Wilder Penfield he was operating on
patients who had had epilepsy in order
to make sure that he wasn't damaging
important parts of the brain he would
stimulate the brain while the patients
are awake and they could report their
sensations and some patients when he
stimulated them actually had quite
complex memories and you may think that
rather goes against the case that Marx
and I have made against the Bray against
the notion that the brain is a
sufficient condition of experience no it
doesn't these were waking patients so
already wakefulness was present and
they'd had those memories in the normal
way first of all so let me just end by
reminding you about the difference
between a necessary and sufficient
condition we're talking about London in
order to be knocked down by a bus in
London I have to be in London I'm very
pleased to say that that's not a
sufficient condition of my being knocked
down by a bus in London otherwise I
wouldn't be talking to you today that's
fine but I want to surely that's true
exactly but but but I want to press you
a little bit on this idea of
not being a single brain because even
even if we're not wedded to the idea of
brains and bats there's a lot of social
neuroscience going on now where people
are interested in the effect of one
brain on another they are you going to
feel pain differently if you're aware of
another person present what about a
group of people can that influence the
physiological and mental states of
people in a way that's to do with their
nervous system so I mean I see one might
be against a certain kind of
individualism but but have you got the
wrong target and thinking the only
target here would be a brain-in-a-vat
or something more distributed more
social that might sustain some of the
things you're talking about much more
distributed one of the irritating things
you find is the toothache settles down
when you go to the dentist and that's a
very good example of the kind of thing
you're talking about certainly the
toothache matters less but hang on why
does it matter less there's a whole
institution of the reassurance that we
get from people who've been qualified as
dentists at cetera cetera and you can
already realize that the authority of
the dentist and your reassurance comes
from an extraordinarily complex society
the society that I've described as being
put together out of a trillion cognitive
handshakes we still need our brains of
course it's a final common pathway but
what our brains are tapping into is
something that has been built up over
hundreds thousands of years and that's
the culture that you can't find by
looking at the brain I repeat the
metaphor I gave it to Ozzie at idle talk
trying to look at the brain and finding
things like love and wisdom and so on
and it's bit like listening to the Acorn
through a stethoscope and hoping to hear
the Whispering Woods the community of
minds is absolutely central to what it
is to be human being and that is not to
be found inside individual brain for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you